hey welcome everyone so today with this
lecture I really wanted to honor late
with the Archana who passed away
recently so first I want to get started
with this game so why to move on how to
continue
okay so so yeah night up seven it's not
the kind of trade you want to do so how
do we find moves like nine eight seven
so how did you know how you saw the game
huh how did you find nine eight seven
you don't know so like so why did you
think so what did you calculate after
ninety seven so one way you look for
this kind of move is because so many of
white pieces are aiming at the King
right so Knight is here the Bishop is
here so just one like just at this point
white played Queen d2 defending this
night on g5 takes takes and now so many
pieces are aiming at the King so when
you have so many pieces aiming at one
direction and it kind of gives you clue
what to look at so in the game nine
eight seven was played taking advantage
of this pin so night if someone doesn't
really work because you don't have a
very good way of taking advantage of
this pin actually another question so
instead of so blacks last move was route
p8 and rugby it just afraid this night
so the knight can jump to d4 how would
you evaluate this endgame let's say
white exchange a buck exchanges
everything
no I agree I think white is better and
white advantage is very long-term
because we have to do the two bishops
and then we have this weakness that's
going to be very easy to target so this
weakness it is of course it's also a
weakness in the middle game but when in
transition to endgame becomes becomes
more relevant because once I Castle
queenside I move my Bishop how are you
going to defend this pawn so in the end
in the middle game there are a lot more
dynamic so it's harder for y to take
advantage of this weakness or even well
and the fact that I still have my Bishop
it makes like this Bishop a little you
know it's not so easy to develop this
Bishop and not so clear what white is
going to do but okay so let's see rugby
eight nine eight seven
so after King gate seven yeah Queen
eight six and then we get to connect Rob
on g6 2 and the king is going to be very
lonely okay so how to continue our
attack okay let me actually just show
this so here
because of the pen so here we have
several options we don't have a good way
to bringing in the rook so yeah we can
just take and okay we have three pawns
and this King is just horrible and at
the very least you can always perpetual
if you don't find anything else or if
you mess up so it's always it's always
nice to be in a position like that when
it is basically you're playing with a
guarantee because if you don't find
anything better you can always just make
a perpetual so okay so like they don't
take black played rocky eight so how do
we continue
we need to bring more pieces right with
moon eight-six right so 95 so okay so
let's say f4 so what happens so now I
might start I'm going to try to do
something like check and you cannot take
because I have a discovery so now I
don't know whose kink is worse so now
our night on 87 did its job so there's
no point to have a night at 97 so we
need to fix our piece 95 so blood cannot
take because take take and you cannot go
after 6 if you move your queen yeah if
you move your queen and I'm going to do
that yeah Bishop f6
so instead plug plate a little plate
here takes takes Bishop d5 one more
accurate move
do we take the bishop do we not take the
mission can't take the bishop yeah
because if we take the bishop
unfortunately all our sacrifices
so yeah castle Bishop c4 and a
four-block resigned so of course at this
level being having Queen versus two
pieces there's really no point in
continuing the game like it so let's
move on
oops
so learning about middle games can be
very complicated because we have so many
books on and games and openings it's
much easier to learn those parts of the
game middle game is much more
complicated there are just so many
aspects to it so one good way to learn
how to play the middle game is learn
your openings and not memorize your
openings but understand ideas like after
you make your moves and you're done with
your opening everyone even strong
grandmasters they like to sit down and
take a good thing and think about what's
coming next but it's very important to
understand why you put your pieces where
you put them it's very easy to memorize
your openings and then blitz all your
moves and then you don't know why it's
my night here why is my bishop here like
what's my plan and so that's one good
way to do it and it's a I know those
transitions are very hard from opening
Camila gaming into endgame so it's a lot
of the everyone struggles with them it's
not an easy thing to do so so let me
I'll talk about this game and I'll talk
about those things while I go over some
of this game so I need to flip this okay
so this game was playing us
Fabiana and i'm sure i've run those who
Fabiana is by now when when five Yana
was only twenty seven hundred five years
ago
he was 85 yeah so it was a very
impressive game by Carson I'm sorry 45
I'm not going to talk about the opening
so much but is everyone familiar with
the Royal office so royal office is a
very interesting opening and it's very
good to study royal office because a lot
of times because of the pawn structure
is sometimes they can turn into
something that's similar to the night or
of sometimes similar to Kings Indians so
when you study real opaz you can learn a
lot of different structures and pawn
structures are another good way to learn
more about video games because the way
you put your pawns or how you put them
really determines where your pieces are
going to go so the three again I got I
don't want to focus too much on this
so so far not too unusual so black
definitely is not hiding his intentions
can gauge aid it's very clear where
blacks plan is so because because of the
structure and because of this Bishop
white is the one who's going to try to
play in the center with something like
before with the nights out and Bishop
bishops in the center so black has to
find counter play somewhere else so 90
to f5 okay so what to do with white now
how do we approach a position like this
like when you're looking for a more what
like what goes through what do you think
what goes through your head no but why
why do you think you have to move your
knife no pictures not going to get
tribal could be sure we can capture the
night so it's a good idea to evaluate
and summarize positions as you go
especially when a lot of changes happen
for example if you'd trade off a lot of
pieces you want to stop and evaluate
because the nature of the position has
changed and you don't want to play it
the same way you're playing when you
have like four pieces instead of now you
have two pieces so what is blacks plan
so black is gonna like it's very clear
right like it's going to push his pawns
on the kingside so as why do you have to
think about where do you want your
pieces to be when that happens and how
you can stop this attack because you
don't want this pawns to just start
rolling and you're not doing anything so
so what is going to be white play
I'm not looking for them like wait like
are you going to plan the queenside
kingside center yeah something so it's
not going to be really on the kingside
because blacks plays there and the
spawns are rolling and obviously you
have to stop this plan so you cannot
just completely ignore your king side
but for a counter play or if you want to
prove this i-5 move to be weak you can
you have to do something you're doing
like you won't really want to do
something in a center to open up the
position or something on the Queen side
actually Fabiano took this right away
and i'm not sure if it's a good idea so
maybe it would like a four just to start
harassing this knight and push them away
so you can make d4 happen because once
you play d4 and the open opens up I'm
sorry the Center opens up it's going to
benefit white because white pieces are
this bishop is going to be strong and
maybe this King will be a little
uncomfortable so now you have four now
black is really committed because the
pawn is on f4 pilot if five is more
fluid I can take I can live it I can
push so there's a lot of options but
once you commit to f4 now I can take so
now this bishop is very strong so I
wouldn't say it's a Kings Indian but it
has Kings Indian kind of ideas behind it
so now black is really committed to
doing something on the King side but
because the pawn is here now we can try
to stop with with moves like h3 and then
put the knight back okay and then see
how like is going to continues attack
and try to do something in the center
again so far beyond I decided to take
it should be five so of course the
bishop on day five is quite strong so
black to move
but a change happen in the position so
the trade has happened so it's important
to consider how this exchange change the
nature of the position so why is the
bishop only seven but right so this is
what I meant when I said like the pawn
structures really determine your plans
because if you don't want to end up
being stuck with this Bishop so when you
have a bad piece like this or a pawn
structure like this you want to be
mindful of how you're exchanging your
pieces so black need to find some kind
of activity so what to do
yeah g5 so how do we know that it's okay
to play g5 how do we know when it's okay
to make a move like this and when move
like this is just going to get us
checkmate it in the next five moves yeah
okay that's true the white pieces are
not very active exactly so the center is
closed so your opponent cannot open up
the center because one if the center
opens up your king is going to be weak
so that's a very significant thing
because if you have your control of the
center or the center is closed then you
can stop playing on the King side
without your king getting in so much
trouble so how should white continue to
face how facing this attack actually
black is a threat correct what's the
threat before your knight is trucked so
what to do right
oh you're raising your hand now the
right if you can play before if you can
get the center open that would really
benefit benefit you because then you can
make this King more vulnerable and get
your pieces into the game but right now
there's a big threat g4s just going to
trap this night so h3 so usually you
don't want to play moves like this
because after g4 you have an unpleasant
choice either you have to take an open
up file so you have to let your opponent
take so g4 so takes takes Knight h2 so
unfortunately for black this Bishop is
in the way so Queen cannot get out okay
so what now
so how to defend upon what happens when
blog starts pushing like g5 before yeah
so there are holes in the position so
this g4 pun can either be a weakness or
a strength so for it to be a strength
black needs to find a lot of activity
because in the long term things like
this can become a weakness so why pick
up g5 right so first of all you're
improving your bishop so we said this
bishop is a bad piece but now position
has opened up a little bit so there's a
diagonal for the bishop and you're
opening up your Queens of course if
you're in a tag you need your queen and
also you're defending your pawn
tactically I cannot take because this
knight hangs so it's a multi-purpose
move so these are the kind of moves that
really help our position we're getting a
lot of things on improving a piece
opening up another one defending
something so one move accomplishes a lot
so Knight c4 is played
so b5 so plug gets rid of this bishop
so again a lot of things have changed in
the position so what has happened I'm
talking about changes in the position
like I'm not talking about something
like overly sophisticated like things
have changed like what happened in your
position like you always have to think
about this kind of things when you're
playing like I exchange pieces like how
why is this important did I go okay okay
so with that rid of our block back left
issue okay so what else is going on
so how do we water keep improving this
position how do we want to continue
right so 90 cents I like to smoke
because the smoke first you might want
to trade this bishop second is this
bishop is very annoying being in the
center and second you might want to
bring the new piece so f3
so why do we want to trade off that
bishop no no no that's where so we trade
up the bishop so another trade has
happened so what was that Bishop doing
on d5 that was bothering us right so now
again so things have changed so your
opponent played f3 so what does that
mean what a position okay well we don't
have a dark square Bishop so at the
moment not too significant was true yeah
okay so we have a picture versus a night
so now that the pawn is on f3 versus on
f2 does it make sense to have a queen
and a rook on that file
so yes no no okay so not really right so
again you have to ask yourself this kind
of questions to find ideas because if
you don't then you're just looking at a
position you don't know where to look at
but when you opponent play something
like f3 it really like lawn moves it
really changes the position so now that
the pawn is on f3 there is no purpose of
having these two pieces here because
you're not really attacking anything so
now your opponent is the one who's
trying to create counter place so first
of all your Bishop is not even developed
so your keys are not connected so if you
let me take and then I play something
like rook f3 my Queen comes in or again
it's not clear who's attacking who so
how do we keep this pressure going
require right so root G so you
definitely don't want to trade and
invite this rock in so Rock g8 so rotate
you have a threat which is
I was thinking q3 and Queen h4 which
looks annoying but another very
important thing is you're still keeping
the pressure and again keeping on with
the changes of the position you had all
this get you plate palm pushes opened up
the F file and everything is great your
opponent defends it doesn't make sense
anymore so you have to switch and find a
new idea so it's very important to keep
to keep like track of the position and
all these changes so Queen g3
so takes takes Bishop f5 so we develop
the bishop to a nice square okay fun
rook g5 so again a multi-purpose move
defending the bishop threatening to
double my rooks so here 28 6 g8 so when
you have all your pieces on put squares
and they all look almost perfect you
want to start looking for like you have
this great advantage you want to find a
way to really capitalize on this
advantage so now it's time to start
looking for tabs tactics and things like
that so that's a good time to look for
tactics when you're all your pieces are
just great and you have complete control
of the position
so our rooks are great double Queen
Bishop like every piece is all almost
everything is on its perfect square do
we want to exchange coins so we don't
want to exchange points because we're
attacking and so if you can exchange
Queens and win material that might be
worth it so this is another thing to
keep in mind when you're attacking don't
get so focused on your attack you forget
everything else if you can trade on
Queens and go into winning endgame
sometimes it happens not every attacks
ends in a checkmate but what's weak in
white position okay so okay so I can
play something like g3 but okay but
let's first before we find most we need
to find what's weak in the position
which are the targets yes
okay so roofie three hangs a piece but
again my question is so what are the
targets in whites position okay so the
night what else I don't know I want to
say the queen is a target so there is it
so first of all g2 is also a target
right or attacking there's another one
that's under attack right now even if
it's protected it's still a target d3
very obvious right Bishop is there so we
have to go after these targets so White
has a lot of weaknesses so it's not it's
not easy to hang on when you have this
many weaknesses
so how can we attack one of them
okay so coin g6 very nice move so you're
defending your bishop
tripling triple link on the G file so
what would happen so white played rugby
one so what will happen with rugby -
Ruby - no sorry rookie trims played
so now pick up d3 so so you of course if
rook the 3.4 so again when you're in
control of a position when all your
pieces are perfect it's not surprising
that you have all this kind of tactics
so King g1 so we've got the advantage
it's very important to be precise so
pawn to e4 take another pawn up to five
so wise position is just falling apart
so when you're under pressure the whole
game it's very easy to collapse but at
the same time it's very hard to suggest
with moves for white because so many so
many targets you're just down to pounds
by now so Queen eight six look at seven
we trade we have sex
so again same thing the Queen's not
doing much or just going back so Black
Swan is simple so now there is nothing
going on the G file so back on the F
well so thread is to play rocket fades
and checkmate on on that file so takes
so this before move I don't really
understand I'm not sure why he wouldn't
just check and keep this pin so I'm not
sure about this before move so here in
g7 so 23 so what will happen if we trade
and take the pawn
so white one upon back but now we're in
an endgame so again a big change in the
position so what was the plan for black
now right so now you can just roll your
pawns down the board so position is
still very bad for white because this
Bishop is just done this Bishop is
dominating the knight this rook is very
random on h3 so you can just push and
it's this pawns are going to be
unstoppable so as I was saying not every
attack hmmm and in a checkmate so you
can just straight down to an winning
endgame and this is especially true if
you end up winning material so Queen III
takes takes wins another pawn to h5
okay so let's find a continuation here
so even with few pieces on the board the
king is still quite weak so we can still
attack before you mean so on there are a
lot of ways to win here I'm sure so so
d4 let me see what I can do I don't have
Queen h3 because I'm getting weighted
yeah the floor looks good yeah
cannot argue with the four yeah yeah so
Queen a one now
whip up on
25 and white resigned because if you do
something like this I'm just going to
chase you away and you're getting Maidan
on f4
or actually I can do no no I don't do
that before it's just good I was
calculating something that is like now
so yeah I really like this game because
there are several aspects to it so first
of all I wanted to show this idea block
just playing g5 and talk about when it's
okay to play things like that and I'm
actually going to show another game
where white played g4 and talked about
that specific position but also main
thing I want to focus on is how the
position changes and how it's important
to keep track of these changes of course
this happens in the endgame and all in
the opening tube but in a middle game
because there's just so many things
going on so many piece interactions it's
very important to keep track and it's a
how important it is to constantly
summarize the positions and you know
have the flexibility to change your plan
like he was attacking on an F file and
then he moves to the G file and then
came back to the F file so he was
flexible enough to keep to keep track of
the weaknesses and to know how to switch
plans and identify the weaknesses and be
able to go after them so next game
Fisher game
no training coach nice blog again okay
say 46 is anyone familiar with this
opening so it's a pretty different so
what can you tell me about the opening
so Black is giving up the center so when
you're giving up the center you need to
find a counter play somewhere else
you cannot just give up the center into
nothing so black beyond shadows the
bishop and black is trying to attack
this d4 pawn white with a move like c5
to open up the bishop to counter the
center a little bit and get some more
space so c5 so what to do there's a
little trick to this opening do we take
25 so the point is you're going after of
course your opponent cannot do something
like this and then all of a sudden King
in the center this Bishop open and so
this is the whole point of this line
this Queen a5 trick Castle 96 so okay
White has a better control better center
with this two pawns but like is the
fianchettoed Bishop so black is going to
try to play mainly on the Queen side and
blacks play so white well okay white
slaves mainly going to be on the King
side and in the center and blacks play
is going to be mainly on the Queen side
so night here a5 so what what the
purpose of most like this right first of
all if the knight is headed on v3
eventually we want to kick it kick it
off and another reason is it's a
provoking move we want to see how is
white going to react to this move and
white is not playing very aggressive or
very active so what is not really doing
anything in the center we're not under
attack there is no direct threat so it's
okay to put make a move like this so you
do not make a move like a five if
there's something happening in the
center if your opponent has some kind of
a direct play so you don't have time to
play a move like a five but here your
opponent is retreating taking a piece
away from the center so you have time to
play a five so really provoking we want
to see what is white going to do really
asking your opponent to a four so now
that the pawn is a four so what's week
before so night before so g4 so move
like this is not very uncommon for this
opening but how is just g4 different
from the g5 in the other position
so that is open
what else
so you want to be able to say as many
things about the position as you can
even if you think something is very
obvious sometimes just because it you
know like you think it's obvious but
then it's so relevant like you think
it's so obvious it's irrelevant almost
it's just there but it's very important
to list as many things about the
position as possible yeah so the bishop
on g7 is very strong
so I'll mention something very obvious
too so pawn on c2 is under attack what
else is under attack for white b4 and c4
so okay so unlike in the other position
where white black went f5 to 5 here
White's position is a little more loose
so what's the piece that's really
keeping it all together for what
defending everything the Queen so it's
very hard for one piece to just defend
the whole position because one piece
cannot do everything so how can we take
advantage of this tension so now we have
to evaluate so before we make a move one
of the most important things of
calculation is evaluation because even
if you calculate a nice long line and
then at the end your words then there's
no need to play it but actually it
happens a lot of people because people
like to look it's like it's hard to find
moves when there is nothing concrete
it's very easy to play a concrete line
because at least you're making a move at
least you're moving because otherwise
you're looking at a position you just
don't know what to do so a lot of times
I see even with my students they play
like down a concrete line and then I ask
them well what you think about this
position and they like oh yeah I'm worse
here and like and the reason I think
they played and like it happens to me
too it's like sometimes you look at a
position just don't know what to do and
then you see this concrete line and then
you're like okay at least again I can
make some moves but let's evaluate
what's going to happen in that position
so let's see if our line works or not
but okay let's go down this line so
takes takes and 92 so what's going on so
now everything is on the red tag so this
is a very concrete position that
requires a lot of calculation we have a
lot of metal games they are very quiet
very strategic this is not one of them
so I mean so many things hanging would
sacrifice the piece so first of all was
the material
okay so we have to be two pawns for a
piece so another important thing is we
took this g4 pawn we exchanged that
light square bishop so White's King is
actually maybe in a long term can be
Wickard so now a lot of pieces are
hanging this is hanging this is hanging
if the knight moves I take the rule
group moves I take the knight so what to
do with white so white decides to
salvage the position so what now so
still we want to be accurate because
okay white has two pieces we have two
pawns but against two minor pieces so if
they somehow get in the game if now I
would worry about it's like this pawn
comes to f5 if we allow this knight back
into the game we can start having some
problems because we have the two extra
pawns but they're not passed pawns we're
not really doing anything with them so
far so it's important to keep being
accurate so what to do okay can we play
more temple moves maybe something that
attack something 26 so I fight now the
scary thing
not what to do
d5
yeah the first possible actually I like
the five but black decided to be greedy
and take another part so how can we win
another pond yeah Quincy for so why a
block is really not scared of this
attack and it's not very it's like this
attack doesn't look very scary because
this night is gonna be five the night is
on a one so it's not clear which piece
is going to check medium but I didn't
but I I agree does look scary whenever
the sponsor put being pushed on the
board well yeah so here so he takes
another pawn ninety-seven so do we take
or so we're up material so we can't
afford to do so we can just give it back
we don't have to hang on to it so again
the king is very safe of course you're
going to take with the F pawn and
because you have whenever you have this
fianchettoed Bishop as long as this
bishop stays your king stays quite safe
because even after something like this
now your queen is on the diagonal so
you're still safe
so white tries to keep the tension on
because if you're done material and
you're just trading of course it's just
going to be bad so now so you need to be
accurate how to define the c7 so you
have two moves right either this rule
comes to eat or this one so which one is
better
and what difference does it make
look the other we don't get there are
more one
one
to
yeah so this one so what else happens
when they're under Brooke is no longer
on f8f sam is a lot weaker so black has
a softer route k-8 was played so usually
we don't do some things like this right
we don't put a rope here and plug this
rock in like we know route this route
goes to see it like we learn this really
well so this rope has to go to c8 and
this rock stays here and usually it's
nothing to do that so in most positions
you would play rook fe8 because it
doesn't make sense to like in both of
your rooks and neither one can move but
here it's very important and it's very
significant so it's very important to be
accurate in the position again keeping
track of what's going on and you even
though you're up to pawns actually have
three pounds you're still under a little
bit of pressure so as long as you
survive this pressure you're going to
have your extra material so rook f e8 so
what would Y do push to f6 so the
problem is if you take take now F 7
hangs and Bishop h6 is a threat so your
phonin has two devastating threats which
actually I don't even see how the both
can be stopped so this actually looks
just +4 black
but if you play rook e8 after f6
you can take take and then you can just
put a rope here and if the Queen stays
on the diagonal you can still go after
this one
but even so Bishop h6 is not even a
threat yet because this rope hangs so
looks like a small like doesn't look
like a big thing but it makes a big
difference so there should be 5 so our
Queens under attack
so take right so tank it should be five
finally making it right so Quincy one
need six same two right on h2
so what to them
okay let's count the material again so 1
2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 so you still have the
three pawns wear it up in exchange so
when whenever you have this kind of big
material advantage you don't have to
hang on to it you can give some of it
back just to simplify the position
that's an important thing important
thing to keep in mind when you're
attacking a lot of times not a lot of
times sometimes people get carried away
sacrifice sacrifice sacrifice and then
they have nothing to play with and then
but also when you your opponent
attacking and sacrificing a lot you can
always keep in mind or can give some of
the material back and stop the attack
and still have advantage but here it
doesn't seem like White has a loan yeah
doesn't seem like White has a lot so if
white takes your rope you're very happy
because this annoying dark square Bishop
is gone so the now the key is to
untangle somehow so now we want to get
our pieces in ourselves I don't think
it's that scary it looks like it looks
fine to me he took on f5 so take take so
the reason I'm taking on f5 so again
they're not in this position there are
no attacks against this King goes Bishop
25 is a monster your own King is not
very safe so simple idea I want to play
here I'm going to play Rock g8 rope 2 3
and end the game so white took to check
take with the night because if you don't
do this if you just take the pawn
which is going to be game over so this
is a common trick to take to put an idol
next five just to have a strong night so
Queenie six and simple palm push
okay one final move in the game always
important to be precise in your games so
he actually there's a tactical way to
just simplify and send the game but of
course yeah you can take with the bishop
team cause there are no checks so how to
use this a pawn
yeah Quinn takes two three
and a lot of times in the games you have
a lot of continuation but the most
precise one is going to end the game so
yeah in this game I thought here it
punish is a point really nice and for
playing g4 and after he did that he
played very precisely and he played very
energetically so because in this kind of
position where you have material
imbalance no it's very important not to
let your opponent pieces in very
important to keep going after this
weaknesses and making sure you on kinks
a slave and I think he did really great
here so this is it for this game
you